- good one I think new media is at a
crossroads where we are no longer about
technology we're about culture and that
means we have to listen to those that
create and lead culture that can be
artists that can be academics that can
be those in government and politics and
you know in the Civic sector but it is
no longer the realm of those that know
computer programming and those that know
how to use you know the hardware the
best like that that moment is over and
technologists are going to be reluctant
to let go of that you know we are those
of us that know technology get very fat
full of ourselves and say Allen's means
I'm a I'm a wizard I have an expert you
know the way they talk about
technologies that like it's magic but
our responsibility now is to building a
culture that is supportive of people
expressing themselves that's inclusive
of those that don't have access to the
latest technology don't have the
resources to spend a lot of time
learning it and and so what what we're
faced with now in the world of new media
is making sure we're creating
environments that everybody can
participate in and making sure we're
encouraging a culture of inclusion and
frankly we haven't been that good at it
if you go and look around the world of
new media right now they will tell you
that everybody has a $500 smartphone and
I can tell you that's not everybody you
know or they'll tell you oh everybody
knows how to use a web browser everybody
has email and those things are barely
even true they're common certainly and
people that want to learn them have at
least a way to learn them but they don't
know the potential of them yet so I
think the real innovations that are
going to happen in the media are going
to be about bringing that cutting-edge
really broad set of tools that we have
you know the fanciest trick you could do
in Photoshop the most advanced and video
editing tool bringing it down to a level
that anybody can do it and do it within
their means within the resources they
have those are going to bring about the
real revolution so it's going to be
access not invention
and that is a huge cultural change for a
Silicon Valley for the whole tech world
to think instead of what's new what's
really truly broadly available and
people will unlock that they'll figure
that secret out hopefully and hopefully
soon I can't wait to see that happen
I think there's an enormous challenge in
using today's technologies to reach the
developing world to reach rural
communities in the US and part of it is
it requires cultural change from those
developing the technologies we don't
realize the cultural assumptions we make
when we make what we think are features
and software were actually defining
culture and there's a million examples
of this one I also point to is for many
years Facebook had it's complicated
as a relationship choice how you can
define your relationship with someone
and in most of the rest of the world I
think of you know certainly any Islamic
country the idea that you would define
your relationship with somebody as it's
complicated would say a lot about you
and that other person that maybe you
don't want to say right and so your
software is reflecting a social value
that is certainly not universal and it's
not Universal within our own culture you
know there's a lot of people that would
think it's anathema to to build into
your application the idea that you know
you might have random hookups with other
people as a form of a relationship and
so when you make assumptions like that
you stop a technology from being useful
in developing world even before they've
looked at what it's utility is right for
the beginning you've said this is not
for you this is not your total to use
and so those are the fundamental issues
that have to be addressed is are we
assuming that these tools can be used
appropriately and and I think then
there's the logistical issues the fact
that the phone is a primary interface
for what we think of as the web or the
internet here in the US for the rest of
the world it's happening on a handset I
think you have the issues of shared
computers right one you know we talk
about one laptop per child and things
like that and I think it's much more
likely one internet kiosk per village or
a one-hour slot at an internet cafe per
week you know those are the ways that
technology gets used in the rest of the
world if it gets used at all and
thinking about really rapid access for a
few minutes we
because they cost a lot of money use an
internet cafe radically changes what you
want an application to be able to do
what you want to technology to be able
to do so there's tremendous potential
you know I think there's people that
have you know stars in their eyes right
now about I'm gonna use Twitter to
deliver crop reports to someone in the
developing world that's going to improve
you know their ability to go to market I
think those things are great I hope they
happen but before we can even think
about those things we have to think
about truly respecting and understanding
the cultures that are going to be using
these technologies and building for the
assumptions and the social you know
constraints that they'll be using these
technologies within
I do think we're at an inflection point
about immediacy the the big triumph for
me about blogging was the idea of
permanence that you would what they call
it a permanent link if you look at the
bottom of a lot of blog post I'll say
permalink and it's permanent link for
that information the idea that I'm gonna
create information that will live on
through time and get more valuable
hopefully over time it's pretty
important and then the next step is
immediacy like can I do things in real
time and Twitter has taught a lot of
people about this to some degree
Facebook has taught people about this or
going back 10 or 15 years ago instant
messaging took off and taught people
about immediacy I think it's still been
fairly constrained it's been hard to
immediately publish to a large number of
people to immediately share context or
content with a lot of people and I think
there's been a challenge as to filtering
if there's a constant flow of real-time
information how do you not get
overwhelmed and I look at you know CNN
and there's three different things
crawling across the screen and two
people on screen yelling at each other
and a logo up in the corner and I think
this is if this is what real-time means
this is overwhelming so that's going to
be you know a challenge to solve the
presentation of large amounts of
information in real-time but that idea
of immediately and easily being able to
share it with any number of people that
seems really exciting that seems like
that might be if not the next big thing
than part of the next big thing